Kevin Hart is set to present at the
Academy Awards this year but the
comedian exclusively tells ET he hopes
to host the Oscars in the future I think
when I do eventually host the Oscars I
think that the time will be right and I
think the setting will be a lot more
positive than what it was today this is
a sticky year for the Oscars it's very
very sticky here so I don't think you go
and be a part of the Oscars this year
and not make your presence felt we're
not in a matinee ignorant way while in a
conservative professional way just what
people understand that you do understand
the importance of values and issues in
and bring new people together ultimately
several celebs are skipping the ceremony
after the Academy nominated all white
actors for the second year however the
ride-along actor is looking forward to
attending Hollywood's biggest award show
I'm excited to see my guide Chris Rock
because he's very fond of my host
because I know not only would Chris host
he's gonna address things the way to the
comedian can use it and can bring light
to some issues that are tough issues but
through that comedic lands but to really
still make you think about so it's a
good thing the right guys the right guys
there this year